yale university says it admonished a
white student for calling campus police
when she found a black student sleeping
in their dorms common area facebook
videos of the incident have been viewed
more than one million times
it is the latest example of a black
person reported to authorities for doing
something legal
and ordinary jericha duncan is near the
yale campus in new haven connecticut
jerica good morning
good morning that black student named
lolati shimbala says she was
studying here early tuesday morning in
this building behind me working
on a paper when she decided to take a
break
that's when she says a white student
came into the common area room where she
was sleeping and told her
she was not allowed to sleep there and
then called campus police
well that's when shiambala started
recording
i have every right to call the police
who cannot sleep in that room
luladi ambala was questioned by yale
police for about 15 minutes for taking a
nap
i deserve to be here i pay tuition like
everybody else
i'm not going to justify my existence
here to prove she was a graduate student
she ambala unlocked her apartment door
and provided her student id
but officers wouldn't let her go because
they say they had trouble
confirming her identity private property
and we are police officers here so we
are allowed to do our job
shimbala said the white student whom she
identified as sarah brosh
once called police and accused another
black student
renaissance jean-louis of being an
intruder in the dorm last february
it's just an instance of microaggression
that i think many black students here at
yale experience
in the last three weeks videos have been
widely shared of police being called on
black people
from leaving their airbnb in california
one
two three playing golf too slowly in
pennsylvania
remove yourself from our premises in the
next five minutes please
because the authority the authorities
have been called to holding a business
meeting at a starbucks in philadelphia
there's a good chance if the person was
white they wouldn't have
it wouldn't have gotten that far khalil
gibran muhammad is a professor of
history
race and public policy at harvard this
is an uneven burden being distributed
onto black people and the police are in
the middle of it
yale police say that they followed
protocol the white student who
complained did not respond to cbs this
morning's
request for an interview but police say
that they told her this was not a police
matter
and that she umbala had every right to
be here
john eureka thanks thanks a lot tarika i
mean i
i like the lead that you said john doing
something legal and ordinary this is so
tiring and so insulting
and we keep seeing these stories over
and over again you know howard schultz
said that he wants to have sensitivity
training for his employees
i think the whole nation needs
sensitivity training this keeps
happening over and over and over again
what strikes me too about the story it's
not unconscious bias it seems like overt
this point and i can remember in college
taking a nap in the library and that's
part of
in the common area nora where you're
eating a lot you take a nap
that's enough